Well, internet you've joined us here,
amid a decision making moment.
We're deciding whether or not
to go through with this video.
This is highly suggested.
And it's a tongue, in a mouse trap.
I don't, I don't wanna do it.
I know, I wouldn't wanna do it either.
And the thing is, this is the
smallest mouse trap possible.
And its still packs an absolute wallet.
It's brutal look at it look.
Oh!
Yeah.
Its literally smashed the
Plastic off that thing....
Did it really?
Yeah look, it's now gone.
Well, thankfully...
The tongue is the last place I want that.
Thankfully...
Apart from maybe somewhere else.
There's two reasons your
tongue isn't made of plastic,
and it is the strongest
muscle in the body.
So...
It will look quality.
Oh, for god sake.
The only reason you're not doing this is
because your nose will get in the way.
Well, Ash...
All right, so we're rolling at
2,000 frames a second in HD.
Dan has been pacing ever
since we finished the intro.
Understandably.
Maybe my tongue isn't long enough.
A bee.
what?
Stupid.
Looks like your just having a really,
really dangerous oyster.
Shut up, I can't reach it.
Sorry, your all over it though.
No.
Not too bad?
The lid with it came off.
So gross.
You stuck it out like
give me my tongue back.
Honestly, I can't believe you did that.
That was impressive.
I'm impressed.
It was not that bad honestly.
Not that bad?
No.
Well, if you suggested that video,
you know who you are, and you
probably feel quite guilty.
So, if you see Dan, why
don't you buy him a drink.
Unless you're in a slimmer shirt,
and then Dan will buy you a drink.
No, stop doing that man, yeah.
Fair play.
Well usually I say all the
stuff at the end of the video.
All the calls to action.
But Dan, why don't you do this one.
Feel free to buy a T-shirt.
Press subscribe, follow us on Twitter.
Links below and we'll see
you in the next video.
Slow Mo Guys.